are you the most average human in
America let's find out if you are the
most average human you'll sleep eight
point seven hours a day if you are a man
you'll have 11 erections if you are a
woman you won't have erections if you
are a coffee drinker you'll have one
point eight five cups of coffee per day
and consume anywhere from 80 to 84 grams
of sugar and you'll use 80 to 100
gallons of water you'll pee four to
seven times and poop
anywhere from once in three days to
three times a day you'll work eight
hours if you use social media you'll
spend 40 minutes on Facebook 21 minutes
on Instagram and 77 minutes on tinder
overall you'll stare at screens for 11
hours you'll smile about 20 times a day
you'll exchange 41.5 text messages
you'll fart 10 times you'll touch your
face 256 times and pick your nose four
times
you'll lose 40 to 100 strands of hair
you'll check your phone 150 times and
lie 1.65 times you'll spend only 17
minutes exercising you'll sweat up to
one quart a day you'll blink 21600 to
28,000 800 times you'll take around
5,000 steps depending on how active you
are you'll consume 2195 calories and 1.5
alcoholic beverages you'll breathe
17,000 to 30,000 breaths
you'll make thousands of decisions some
of them will surely be impulsive you'll
swear about 80 times you'll spend five
hours on leisure you'll laugh twenty
times your heart will beat 100,000 times
you'll average 46 minutes of driving
you'll watch 2.8 hours of TV you'll fall
asleep in seven minutes and you'll have
four to six dreams all in an average day
so how a verge are you let your friends
know and share this video so they can
find out how average they are
[Music]